[Music]
in human tale news yes your dream you
want to tail yep she wants to be a
marsupial evil your cats have tails yeah
I know you all cuz that's what you
people grow tails you don't know if you
grow horns and Tails nope
are you picturing a possum tail like a
rat tail or you picturing a donkey tail
oh I'm picking a giant fluffy squirrels
thank you
well I like a red panda dude she's just
gonna tell you that people are growing
like little nub tails like you know what
if you had a tail going in the back then
you can [ __ ] two girls at once I know
man it's been a long time it's not asked
to feels anymore really shut it down you
just stopped having sex no more stories
submitted by address your best Japanese
researchers built a robotic tail to help
keep the elderly up right so they could
sit on it - oh yeah it's like here you
go grandma's problem well so they do
which is Q over so I have a video to
show oh yes of them you the tail oh my
god you know creepy this is our human
ancestors evolved to lose their tails
but now elderly people who are unsteady
on their feet could be helped by this so
it helps them balance that's creepy
don't tell anymore
yeah can't they make it cute the grave
one meter device heavy [ __ ] looks like
it's gonna break their [ __ ] back yeah
it's like a robotic leeches like in
their spine
this is a tale that helps people balance
for example when a human tilts the body
like this the tail moves in the opposite
direction then that's what the tilted
direction the tail keeps balance Wow
that's an alien [ __ ] entering I
should like add fur or something that's
just the inside guys that's what yes
like Cookie Monster's it's like a cat
the team are also investigating it's
industrial applications okay I tell them
excited for warehouse workers carrying
heavy loads oh it's like wagon without
him no yeah so they're saying that other
nations are looking to turn to like
immigrant workers to replenish the
shrinking workforce because everyone's
aging but it's dead Japanese people are
using monkeys no Japanese people are
focusing on a more technological
solution to keep their people work that
makes sense
oh oh they are the robot peoples they
make lots of robots I don't know I feel
about this because I'm not a big fan of
crutches like you know like if when
someone like sprains their leg or
something right
usually when you get like of an actual
literal crutch you also go through
physical therapy so you can strengthen
the muscles or the tendons
if you sprained your knee or your ankle
or whatever so you can make your body
its own corrective theme so when all
people instead of relying on the tail
because what ends up happening is
anytime you have a crutch all the other
muscles that control will start to
atrophy cuz I'll go oh I don't need a
balance we got a balancer so their core
muscles or leg muscles whatever all the
other muscles will start we're actually
dwindle at a more exponential rate
versus if all these workers if there are
if they are older if they just have
mandatory like one hour very light
exercise in the morning to activate
their core muscles their glutes and
hamstrings and all that to help them
wean off of this if they need it
immediately I think they should put the
tail line but as much as they use the
tail I think they need to choose to to
strengthen all the muscles the body can
depend on itself I heard that like when
old people have a lot of knee problems
and it starts to go downhill really fast
let's do two their shoes and then
they're using all these corrective
shoot things instead of strengthening
all those little muscles in their feet
yeah they do grandma's they get
grandma's to start squatting and even on
like a soft pillow where they have to
use stabilizer muscles and they
immediately often don't need to use
canes Walker's anymore yes they're just
strengthening all the muscles that are
going away but think about how adorable
it would be to have a whole bunch of old
Japanese people with tails different
color you see the application being
awesome and like surfing or
skateboarding or it's things that you
need balance in and [ __ ] tight tight
rope motorcycle riding imagine oh it's
just waving around yeah keep any balance
this is doing it for you that's kind of
lit we all become Sonic the Hedgehog his
friend the Fox will Hales Sony the
Hedgehog instead of Sonic that's that's
good deed I wasn't there either I've
just heard the story he's not good it's
one of the most classic JK moments you
had to be there no no it's really funny
you should watch it yeah go watch him
I'm just getting party sonic tails what
the thing is this thingy super sized she
bought the gift he's about to give to
she it's a tushy
you are we so dumb he's doing the bow
like so
oh yeah he's appointed crazy about you
grab it you it feels like it's dying to
me
hi yeah it's kind of sad it's getting
replaced by robotics not like it's
something that was thriving and I get
this feeling at Vegas too like there was
it there was it's time like its heyday
right and then only because I I remember
going there as a kid to like my yeah it
feels like that balls are dying yeah
Japan feels like that to me I mean I
guess not in the main city but still
like it feels like there's just less
people there's less things going on
there's there's no new things like the
buildings look like it's getting a
little old yeah especially when we were
in our way up because do you remember
there was a ton of migrant workers there
and then it's just weird to me because
it's one of those places where I'm not
used to it being diverse oh so just
having seen so much diversity especially
in like a smaller city how come the
migrant workers just reinforce the
stereotypes it's all the family more
Indians at the convenience doors maybe
Indians worldwide like to work at
convenience stores yeah maybe it's
passed down these are even else I'm like
internationally this is Indian that
convenience stores is crazy yeah all the
construction workers and just all kinds
of stuff and I was like man this is
crazy Mexican the taggers working no
just pause it just felt like less
population to I don't know it was just
weird I don't have anything to compare
with because it Japan's a new things in
my life yeah see that's I think that's
the thing is most people going it's just
they're going there on vacation and they
don't see it yeah but you know how like
there's the whole population issue
there's less kids being popped like all
this stuff I haven't been yet you ever
been me neither
trying to go should all go I want to go
bro it's pretty cool bro that's like
commit that's like the one city on my
list of [ __ ] like places I really want
to go
you can afford it I can but I can't go
yet because she I can't travel yet oh
gee I I've got a tile I'm like 20 years
ago but people told me that now it's
like super technologically like advanced
it's changed so much and just even past
like ten years I used to think it was so
funny because they'll be a skyscraper
and right next to it there's like a farm
in a hut in Japan no like a No okay I
like you would drive around and there's
like skyscrapers and in like a block
away there's like a village like huts
and [ __ ] what do you even like even like
that the the poor and the rich people
are I mean I feel like it's a lot of
countries like this - it's like super
disconnected you don't saying because
even when I was a little kid I go there
and it would be like a really nice like
almost like mansion and then literally
like a block down people living in like
a hut yeah I'm saying like ten roofs and
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah towns like that -
yeah yeah that just blew my mind man cuz
I was like this is cool now you know
depends not dead it's got tails let me
know next time you guys go I'm trying to
go you want to get a robotic tail out
there for my mom yeah she's falling all
the time no we should have like another
trip there cuz it'll be really fun and
then we'll go to Thailand afterwards
okay I've never been a Thailand that's
like the my last place on my bucket list
you're like you know that's the last
place you want to go yeah like I
actually I wanted the last thing before
kids but I don't know if that's gonna
happen before kids
there's the pulse gonna try then this
year Tyler yeah we're talking with Alec
about it me and my ever happen I forgot
I got working tomorrow you're supposed
to connect with his wife or something
plan about speak English you guys said
no no no peas you're like cuz you're
like you're like this you're like you're
like don't talk to Bart he's not grass
schedules I don't remember the you talk
to me about yeah that was Alec you know
Alec yeah never like [ __ ] Alec in
Thailand is [ __ ] bondo it's like
Amanda's there's so many tourism things
like it's just it's a good mix of tour
this [ __ ] and like traditional [ __ ] and
it's like it's not far from each other
yeah the beaches yeah yeah you gotta go
to make sure going with the little
islands off the coast of Thailand yeah
that when it's too touristy there's a
lot of scams yeah I got a jetski scam oh
did you yeah
they say have to pay more cuz you went
over time and I'm like no but they
believe me you should just gone over
time then true alright let's do a Japan
ship time and [ __ ] yeah Taiwan we'll get
matching tails okay no I want to be the
only one oh okay I like that River
Market you know that that like never
Martin is like Congress team I'll be
Sonic when you go on the boats and then
they push you and then like you you can
buy stuff from other boats you can find
like a new doze or whatever they stop
yeah boat noodles
yeah bow noodles fire boodles No
[Music]